[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo revive el impulso ciudadano a
favor del aborto legal en argentina el
gobierno envió al congreso un proyecto
de ley para legalizar la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo y la llamada
marea verde volvió con fuerza debido al
cob y 19 el número de manifestantes fue
más reducido que en otras ocasiones pero
el movimiento hizo gran presencia en
internet y tiñó de verde las redes
sociales desde donde apoyan esta
propuesta empezamos la marea verde
volvió a tomarse las calles de argentina
y ante la situación de kobe 19 su
presencia se hizo más fuerte en el mundo
de internet el movimiento que nació
exigiendo el aborto legal seguro y
gratuito resurgió con fuerza luego de
que el presidente al puerto fernández
envió al congreso un proyecto de ley
para despenalizar lo usando una corbata
verde y bajo el numeral que sea ley el
mandatario hizo el anuncio a través de
su cuenta de twitter al que le siguió
una ola de comentarios y contenidos que
inundó de verde las redes sociales miles
de usuarios compartieron desde
reacciones positivas hasta las imágenes
de las movilizaciones que se
desarrollaron
todo el país en apoyo a la propuesta las
plataformas como twitter
instagram facebook y tick tock sirvieron
para promover las convocatorias sus
participantes y organizadores dicen que
estas manifestaciones seguirán hasta que
el proyecto sea ley
es ahora educación sexual para decidir
anticonceptivos para no abortar aborto
legal para no morir es urgente y
prioritario que se sancione la ley de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
para saldar una deuda de la democracia
con mujeres lesbianas bisexuales varones
trans y personas no binarias es una
cuestión de salud pública justicia
social y derechos humanos el objetivo de
los usuarios era claro saturar las redes
sociales con el llamativo color verde y
las reacciones se hicieron llegar desde
ciudadanos de a pie activistas políticos
y hasta organizaciones de derechos
humanos la campaña nacional por el
derecho al aborto legal seguro y
gratuito que es una alianza de
organizaciones y personalidades invitó a
los usuarios a compartir historias de
cómo obtuvieron su pañuelo verde y a
quién le regalarían uno cuando el aborto
sea legal la icónica prenda de quienes
apoyan la interrupción del embarazo se
originó en el país suramericano y se
extendió a territorios vecinos
amnistía internacional cuyo logo siempre
ha sido amarillo ahora es verde en su
cuenta de 'twitter' de argentina en
conjunto con sus cuentas de mexico
brasil chile y otros países de europa
probamos
el numeral luz verde al aborto y
compartieron imágenes de cómo iluminaron
de verde el ministerio de salud y el
cabildo de buenos aires- una forma de
presionar a las autoridades para que
avancen con el proyecto
cuando los gobiernos restringen el
acceso al aborto las personas se ven
obligadas a recurrir a prácticas
inseguras con consecuencias fatales el
actual sistema argentino llevó a que en
los últimos 30 años más de 3000 mujeres
perdieran la vida y otras 39 mil
pusieran su salud en peligro y
presidente del congreso deben dar luz
verde al debate y terminar con una
política de criminalización que ha
demostrado ser ineficaz si el proyecto
de fernández es aprobado marcaría un
antes y un después en argentina durante
el último siglo de la nación
suramericana ha visto varios intentos
por despenalizar la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo pero ninguno ha
tenido éxito el aborto en el país era
prohibido en su totalidad hasta 1921 y
desde ese año este procedimiento sólo
está permitido si el embarazo es
producto de una violación o si la vida
de la persona gestante corre peligro
incurrir en esta práctica implica cárcel
tanto para los pacientes como para
quienes lo practiquen o cooperen en
ellos sólo hasta 2018 la cámara de
diputados le dio el visto bueno al
proyecto pero este murió en el senado
aunque la inmensa mayoría de la
población apoya el aborto también
existen los llamados movimientos provida
éstos impulsaron sus propias campañas en
redes sociales para rechazar la
propuesta bajo las etiquetas no fue ley
y no será ley decenas de personas
empezaron a compartir emotivas historias
de cómo optaron por la vida y decidieron
tener a sus bebés esto como parte de un
intento por dirigirse a los sentimientos
de la gente y reforzar su propaganda en
contra del aborto
ambos hashtags se hicieron tendencia
pero no precisamente por los movimientos
provida sus publicaciones fueron
saboteadas por usuarios pro-aborto que
en forma de broma compartieron relatos
similares mostraron fotografías de los
supuestos hijos que decidieron tener
pero en realidad esas imágenes
pertenecían a estrellas de pop coreano
celebridades como lady gaga o taylor
swift y dibujos animados
los medios de comunicación tanto en este
país como otros de américa latina'
compararon cómo está la situación de
argentina frente a sus vecinos de la
región el diario página/12 entrevistó a
la secretaria legal y técnica de la
presidencia vilma ibarra quien argumentó
que en los países donde está aprobada la
ley baja el número de embarazos no
deseados y de abortos y que eso es lo
que quieren el diario la nación dice que
el presidente fernández se juega un
importante capital político con el
proyecto de aborto y anticipa que el
gobierno utilizará como argumentos la
experiencia de otros países donde su
legalización bajó la tasa de mortalidad
el periódico el país de uruguay recuerda
que el aborto es ilegal en casi toda
américa latina y que solo cuba guyana
puerto rico y uruguay legalizaron esta
práctica sin condiciones el espectador
de colombia publicó una entrevista hecha
a la directora de amnistía internacional
de argentina dice que la discusión del
aborto pese a ser rechazado en 2018 fue
fundamental para generar nuevos
movimientos juveniles que se apropiaron
de la causa y que esto puede generar un
nuevo debate en américa latina' y abrir
la discusión
sobre la legalización en diferentes
países de la región
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos
france24 puntocom
[Música]